this hanging mass is made entirely of
bees the swarm can hold itself together
even when shaken about by the wind now a
team of scientists have been finding out
how about once a year colonies of
honeybees leave their nests in swarms
searching for a new home until they find
a new site the bees rest in these
temporary clusters the clusters often
found in trees but this one is forming
in a lab at Harvard in Massachusetts
little do the bees know they're about to
go for a ride
the researchers built this shaking
apparatus to investigate how the bee
swarm reacts to movement when shaken
from side to side shearing forces act on
the colony with the bees at the top
taking the brunt of it as they try to
hold up everything beneath them the
forces threaten to destabilize the whole
colony so the bees do something clever
they spread out the flatter shape
changes the colonies center of mass and
so it wobbles less reducing the pressure
on the bees it makes sense imagine
you're standing up and you find the
ground shaking beneath you instinctively
you'd crouch down same principle anyway
what's particularly interesting here is
that the forces at play are acting on
the swarm as a whole but each bee can't
see the shape of the swarm so how does
it know where to go or what to do to
find out
researchers trapped the bees on the
outside of the swarm as the colony shook
they moved upwards to where the stress
is greatest
the researchers modeled this behavior
and found that if all the bees follow
the rule move towards the area of higher
stress the colony flattens out
increasing its stability and so
decreasing the average stress on each
bead great for the colony but individual
bees are actively putting themselves
under more stress to do it this kind of
altruistic behave
is not very common in nature except that
is in use social insects like bees and
ants which rely on altruism for survival
what's more even though each individual
bee doesn't necessarily know what's
going on by simply moving towards an
area of higher stress the colony as a
whole acts intelligently this is called
emergent intelligence and some
scientists think that it's through a
process like this that individual
neurons firing in our brain can
collectively come together to make well
us talk about a hive mind